and joining us now on these latest
developments he is the host of CR TV's
Levin TV the host of the hit show Sunday
nights 10:00 Eastern right here on Fox
life liberty and Levin I call them the
great one Mark Levin let me pick up
right where we just left off there the
President of the United States and James
Comey zone words in the memo is saying
do not shut down the investigation if
there are associates of satellites or
people with that around me that did
something inappropriate I want you to
get to the bottom of it I don't think it
gets any more scope Latorre than that
mark these memos actually helped the
president there is nothing incriminating
in them I took 25 minutes to read as
best I could I went through them see
these redacted areas they incriminate
Comey because he said he didn't release
classified information at the bottom of
the number of these pages that says
classified Comey said he didn't classify
information so he's got some splainin to
do but I've gone through this the
president is furious about these
allegations about prostitutes and you
know and so forth and he continually
denies it that didn't happen and so
forth and so on
he's at commis notes and Ed Henry made
the other points but I want to point out
something to Sean which is this so today
as you reported the Deputy Attorney
General of the United States Rosenstein
told the president last week that he's
not a target in the michael cohen case
or the russian case or both cases let's
get something straight I was on your
program back in July last year I've got
two two memorandum one under the Nixon
administration one under the Clinton
administration the Clinton
administration memorandum is 39 pages
long with a zillion footnotes and here's
what it says America and this is what
you need to know that's been going on to
your country the memo is addressed to
the Attorney General of the United
States from the Office of Legal Counsel
which handles constitutional issues a
sitting president Amin ability to
indictment in criminal prosecution the
indictment or criminal prosecution of a
sitting president would
unconstitutionally undermine the
prosody of the executive branch to
perform its constitutionally assigned
functions page after page after page
saying a sitting United States president
cannot be indicted
now my question is this did they issue
another memo over there at the Justice
Department reversing these two memos
during the Nixon administration and the
Clinton administration no no mister
Rosenstein you're the Deputy Attorney
General of the United States you've been
overseeing robert muller if you tell the
President of the United States last week
that he's not a criminal target in it he
can't be a criminal target under the
memoranda that had been written by the
Justice Department
moreover Justice Department regulations
require the special counsel of the
United States to follow the rules
regulations and quote policies of the
Department of Justice mr. president
don't sit down with this special counsel
this special counsel doesn't have the
power to indict you and for good reason
let me read this one paragraph this is
from the Clinton administration Justice
Department in 1973 the Department
concluded that the indictment or
criminal prosecution of a sitting
president would impermissibly undermine
the capacity of the executive branch to
perform its constitutionally assigned
functions I'm hoping professor
gerschwitz is listening we've been asked
to summarize and review the analysis
provided in support of that conclusion
and to consider whether any subsequent
developments of law lead us today to
reconsider modified disavow that
determination please one more sentence
we believe that the conclusion reached
by the Department of 1972 still
represents the best interpretation of
the Constitution they are saying Mr
Muller's boss mr. Rosen Steve's boss
unless attorney general sessions has
rejected the Department of Justice's
position that he's sitting president
cannot be indicted so what are we doing
well you know what they're doing what
they're doing is is that they want to
set up a impeachment possibility exactly
pending on well and that's why this
whole listen it's anybody's
monopoly or any type of board how do you
go from you know Pasco all the way to
boardwalk and Park Place if in fact now
where it's stormy Daniels but I have a
more important question last night
congressman Ron de Santos and and ten
other congressmen sent criminal
referrals for struck and for Paige and
McCabe and Comey and Hillary Clinton
these other people involved in this
dossier then we have the criminal
referral today for Andrew McCabe from
the inspector general walk us through
the legal aspects of this where this
heads next and what I know you have
called for the firing of the Attorney
General and he's a friend of yours over
these you know I did not call for the
firing I said he should step down okay
and I don't I don't I don't really enjoy
it I've known him for 30 years and
here's the problem the Deputy Attorney
General is out of control the president
United States has his shoulders pinned
to the wall it's the job of the Attorney
General to control the Deputy Attorney
General the Deputy Attorney General of
the United States is usurping the powers
of the Attorney General the Attorney
General was confirmed by the Senate he
is a presidential appointee this is what
our Constitution requires an inferior
officer cannot usurp the power of the
Attorney General as mr. Rosenstein has
done I'm going to tell you something
there's a case that's been taking place
in the manner free case they went into
federal district court and they said
Muller is exercising authority he
doesn't have this took place today with
all the rest of this stuff going on I
don't know what this federal district
judge is going to do but you know what
she said in open court they're making a
fair point here mr. Rosenstein gave this
special counsel such such remarkably
broad powers that it may well be
unconstitutional so let's sum up the
deputy director of the FBI
may well be under criminal investigation
because he's a serial leaker the former
FBI director may be a witness against
his former deputy and the deputy may be
a witness against the rhetorical
question who he says is lying
what okay is there's a couple of things
and I want to go back to a question I
asked professor Dershowitz because this
is important
everything that we now know about
Hillary Clinton and if you if I you you
would be my best lawyer I'd call you
you're my friend you're the great one I
call you the great one but if I deleted
33,000 subpoenaed emails acid-washed the
hard drive beat the crap out of devices
or had someone else do it
that would be obstruction of justice you
know it I know what the American people
know it when he wrote called me and his
Trump hating buddies struck the
exoneration before the investigation we
know that the fix was in you don't write
that in Maine you don't interview her
till July which they did and then if we
have a dossier you know and that that
dossier but fara National Russian lies
to a FISA Court judge and don't say who
paid for it and you don't verify it mark
you have said this is a post
constitutional America that's these
instances verify what you wrote in your
last book is a hundred percent accurate
this these are scary times if you
believe in the rule of law equal
application under the law and the
Constitution explained this is the
greatest scandal in modern American
history we have the highest echelons of
the FBI and a lot of former FBI
officials who are friends of mine
because I worked at the Justice
Department agree who are corrupt I don't
mean on the take I mean politically
corrupt and you're seeing that play out
now and you're actually the American
people are getting a real taste of mr.
Comey and they don't like them you're
also seeing the criminalization of
politics and you're also we haven't even
gotten into what the intelligence side
has done let's be honest about this the
Democrat Party nominated somebody who
was under criminal investigation mr.
Comey stepped in and protected her
Hillary Clinton is too stupid to
understand that he protected her from
being indicted not once but twice can
you imagine we could have had a
candidate for federal office indicted
she clearly violated the Espionage Act
not once but repeatedly mr. Comey says
you need specific intent in a contra in
a statute that talks about gross
negligence but we had specific intent
she
perfectly intended to have a server that
was offline they didn't have the
security necessary she knew she would
get classified information and she knew
she would use the right classified
information mr. Comey was a special
Pleader for Hillary Clinton and this is
why the Democrats hated him until the
second after Donald Trump fired him and
then they could make their claim about
Russian collusion obstruction of justice
and try to impeach all right mark thank
you so much the great one you can see in
life Liberty Levin 10 Eastern every
Sunday night Congrats on the success of
the show by the way we love having you
here at Fox